hey Friends of Evan Carmichael and Evan
my friend but he appreciates you doing
this take away on me an obsessed person
doesn't care if they if they don't like
that activity but they have to do it
you're obsessed you're in it you do it
anyway no matter what look if you want
to be in business for yourself and free
you must learn to dominate you cannot
compete you should not get your advice
from people in the middle class about
finances hello believe nation I'm Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn some
motivational speaker trainer and author
Grant Cardone and my take on its top ten
rules of success volume 2 rule number 4
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys as you're watching if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well enjoy
I hear a lot of guys saying right now
like they only do the things you want to
do dude I do stuff I don't want to do
every single day okay so I don't know
who these people are that don't do the
things they don't want to do maybe they
were given a business or something but
I'm gonna tell you something man if you
don't do the things you don't want to do
you're not going to grow your business
you won't keep your business I'm telling
you you have to be willing to do you got
to be so obsessed that you don't collect
care see an obsessed person doesn't care
if they have to clean a toilet
uh-huh you know an obsessed person
doesn't care if they if they don't like
that activity but they have to do it
you're obsessed you're in it you do it
anyway no matter what I remember my mom
told me one day she's like you know
grant I love you just the way you are
because I tell I'm telling her about all
these dreams I have as a child right
yeah and I was reminded when my sister
told me like 30 years later you know
grant you've done a lot we love you just
the way you are and I'm like did I
wonder how many times I've been told
that you know and the fact is so what
they love me just the way I am I don't I
don't love me just the way I am which
opens up to this whole field of people
that's like just love yourself the way
you are look if you're broke you're not
living on purpose you don't like your
job you can't get away from your job
dude if you're stuck in a house you
don't like why would you want to love
that you should become obsessed with
hating it man it's obsessed or average
one of the two so pick just pick get a
t-shirt obsessed or get another t-shirt
average which one would you be more
proud wearing right yeah yeah who do I
want to be man who do I want to be how
do i how do I want to die man I want to
die all in here's the deal guy just hit
me on snapchat and said hey man I'm
going for it cuz I only got one life to
live
and I and I and I snapped him back and
just said hey man what if that one life
thing in true bro and he's not now he's
wondering what you mean man what you
mean I said well here's the deal okay I
mean you don't know and I don't know
right I mean maybe you don't know maybe
I do but here's the deal I'm much more
dangerous and much more of a risk taker
and much more a going all the way dude
and less introverted when I'm not
worried about the one life
myth okay I'm thinking hey baby what if
I live forever man then am I willing to
take the risk
am I willing to make the sales call see
me living forever the immortality
concept makes me way dangerous makes me
sick dangerous makes me crazy dangerous
okay it makes me want to go for it every
freaking single day because I don't have
the ultimate to lose you understand what
I'm saying hey check it out maybe you
know maybe you don't know but I'll bet
you're curious what if you live forever
what if this is like a thousand time
what have you got a thousand more runs
with this deal well then go for it
bottom line is one life or many lives
go for it today go for it in a big way
and go for it like you won't live
forever look if you want to be in
business for yourself and free you must
learn to dominate you cannot compete
okay how many were trained us
competition is a healthy thing that
message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs that message was being
delivered to consumers
there was somebody saying look the more
more oil companies we have to better
because it's good for the customer right
the more technology companies we have is
not just Microsoft the better for the
customer and intermittent inventions and
you know improvements and products comes
from competition but if you're the one
playing the game you want to dominate
the field so look here's the deal I
might be wrong and what I say okay I
might be wrong and the things I do in my
life and the business that I
started my families told me not to start
every business that I've been involved
in every one of them every one of them
was a risk every one of my handed take a
chance I remember my mom used to tell me
I wouldn't do that if I were you I
wouldn't do that if I were you I
wouldn't do that if I were you I might
mommy you wouldn't do anything well you
wouldn't do anything except be the
mother a great mother to five children
my mother was an entrepreneur she didn't
have my dreams just because she's my mom
doesn't mean she dreams like me would
you agree okay
my mom was wrong about everything she
told me not to do love my mom to death
okay unbelievable friend of mine she was
wrong I needed to do those things okay
Steve Jobs needed to build this phone
would you agree did he help a lot of
people did he make some money while he
was doing it 119 billion dollars in five
years in the bank cash I'm not doing
that probably I'm talking about in the
in done in the bank sitting there okay
brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination total domination okay
Exxon total domination you see what I'm
saying you want to be in a dominating
point okay so what we got to do is we
got to get you thinking we got to get
you thinking like the dominators think
how do they act how does Warren Buffett
act what does Warren Buffett do with
this time all the time those are the
people I study today I don't study the
people that I went to school with the
teachers I went to school with
I don't even study my own family members
okay I'm looking for people that are way
up here that I could say okay what are
they doing because they're doing it
right I know that one of the key things
one of the things that's made me
successful in my life is making it a
priority to control my thoughts like
what am I thinking about like literally
putting discipline in on how I talk to
myself and so I don't want this to sound
all psychobabble stuff it's not like
it's not like oh if you just stand in a
mirror and talk to yourself and say
positive things everything is going to
be all right that's not true be careful
what you say to yourself okay because if
you're saying a $30 stake is a lot of
money or a $4 toy is a lot of money when
you're
good months a four dollar toy listen to
what you're saying that's a lot of money
four dollars is a lot of money okay oh
my worst day four dollars has not been a
lot of money even though okay I've been
at periods in my life where I didn't
have four dollars so I'm talking to you
today about how do you control how do
you control how do you discipline how do
you start monitoring what you're saying
to yourself I can't find the right girl
I can't find the right guy there's no
good guys left in this town all men are
pigs women cheat on their men a marriage
is hard having kids is difficult I don't
want to pay taxes you know I can't help
myself I can't stop I can't trust myself
I never do what I say I procrastinate
I'm an introvert I'm broke I'm poor so
what are you saying to yourself all the
time the first thing I did was I took I
took a little journal out and I just
wrote down all the negative things I say
to myself by the way I just gave you the
list okay I can't spend money I can't
save enough money I don't make enough
money okay I don't know how to invest in
the stock market I can't invest in real
estate I don't have time to do this you
know the content people just kill
themselves with the time thing I don't
have enough time I don't have enough
time I don't have enough time guess what
oops you don't have enough time you
don't have time you know I have money
catch yourself every time you say I
don't have time say hey I create time
every time you say I don't have money I
create money or maybe just start just
start literally like talking to yourself
that hey I am a millionaire I am a
multi-millionaire own if you want to if
you're in the apartment game and you
want to be in apartments but you don't
know anything about apartments you can
start literally talkin to yourself
saying I am worth around 100 units I did
this for years for years before I ever
bought an apartment I used to write down
out
Cornie apartments that arms 12% of cash
flow over over I bet I better wrote this
down a thousand times I own 20
apartments my first deal was 38 units I
own 20 apartments or more and I write it
in any little journal any piece of paper
any legal pad every time you say
something negative right now I need to
lose weight
okay it's good but you know if you're
running a race you don't say I need to
finish the race you're like you're
looking for that you got to run right
you got to run you got to move you got
to keep moving your feet so I mean you
can sit there and say I've got to finish
this race but the truth is if you need
to lose weight man just once you pick
your target weight and start affirming
just I weigh 165 pounds I weigh 165
pounds just switch it a little bit right
all you're trying to do is discipline
you're trying to move the river so if
you're broke right now quits a and I am
broke and start saying what you want
where are you going you got to get to
mater's you need haters no school is
going to teach you how to get a hater
okay high school elementary school
colleges what do they teach you want to
be the most popular person now you want
haters okay
the companies that are hated are the
companies that are exploding the people
that are hated are the people that
explode if I don't hate you if nobody
hates you nobody knows you so the reason
I'll tweet for instance when we started
we had this that newsletter that I sent
out okay he send it out every week we
were hitting people once a month and we
started getting complaints you send
stuff out too much my office came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have more people pulling off of the
newsletter good double up again why I
want haters okay so we start sending out
one every week and then I started
Twitter account I actually had people
write grant cardone
social media people grant cardone is an
example of what not to do with social
media
I said freaking
just multiply just increase it okay we
were doing like four tweets a day good
due to an hour why because I want my
competition hating my guts um what I'm
talking about me I mean I don't really
want hate people to hate me you
understand what I'm saying about I want
them so so energized that they actually
start pushing me they start promoting me
I use every one of the news channels if
you'll see me on TV doing news one day
okay i don't i don't watch news i make
news see the shift you see the slight
shift don't watch the news decide when
you leave here today to make the news
right you don't read the newspaper you
write newspaper articles
you don't read books ya read them but
learn to write them and you know you
don't need to take for it you don't need
to spend a lifetime right in the book
this was three hours okay we still forty
thousand copies of this one book and it
was self-published has never ever ever
been in a bookstore a guy writes leases
then you got misspelled words all in
that book i'm like yeah yeah what so
what where are they 123 128 134 165 120
i'm not yeah yeah and bad grammar to i'm
like yeah what's your point dude i know
what's your point man why you keep
telling me that you're right cuz man you
got misspelled words in a book it's a
best-seller
[Music]
okay so it ain't best written okay you
know what I'm not now this war just so
any nobody under think that that's a
cuss word the word to look it up in the
dictionary means a complainer a wine or
an excuse maker I wear a little ban on
my pen here on my wrists here it's a
little black band and it says champions
dominate and on the other side don't be
a little bit yeah that's right because I
don't need it
I need to get rid of the whiners the
excuse makers oh my god is the market
it's the market oh my god your prices
hell we inventory okay now I'm not to go
there's too much inventory now - a
little inventory you human beings have
so many excuses it's unbelievable you
know why because you watch the news too
much because you've agreed to receive
news not make news my journalism
professor said the money will come
follow your heart follow your passion
the money will come that's what was told
to me and he knew nothing about money
otherwise he wouldn't have been in his
job even I thought he should not have
been giving you advice on money he
doesn't have any money you got people
but his measurement of success is not
money and it's been why should you ever
would buy some money that's my point my
dad my dad died when he was 52 okay he
made it in the middle class my mom and
my dad thought they had made it when the
truth is the next week my mom had to
sell the house he had bought so we could
live that is not making it okay you
should not get your advice from people
in the middle class about finances they
don't know anything about finances if
you know what day it is you are not busy
enough I recently heard this week oh
it's Monday man it's so hard to get
started on a Monday I'm like that how do
you even know it's Monday I don't know
what day it is
on Wednesday we hear it's humpback day
we're halfway there so it's Friday and
it's like oh thank God it's Friday or
follow Friday or like - how do you
people know what
you're not busy enough you need to be so
freaking busy that you don't know what
time it is you don't know if it's before
lunch after lunch before dinner after
dinner come on you've had those
productive days remember the day when
you were so productive you you literally
work through lunch and dinner and you
looked up at seven o'clock you should
have been home an hour ago and you're
like did I haven't had lunch or dinner
you know why because that day you were
eating the marketplace you were
consuming the marketplace because you
were active productive hitting it
slamming creative and completely
committed look that's where you need to
be today look I don't know what Monday
Wednesday or Friday are I don't know
about Saturdays and Sundays I know this
create tremendous amounts of activity so
much activity that you lose track of
time your success is not going to come
from watching TV or looking at a
calendar your success is going to come
from activity from being busy from being
obsessed from being like so into it that
you don't know about oh my gosh the
Monday morning blues or Wednesday
humpback or Friday what Friday what
whatever okay
get busy in different places in life I
promise you you're going to find you
don't know where to go everybody goes
through this the most successful people
in the world wake up some mornings with
no clue what to do today okay so first
thing I want you to know is that it's
normal it happens to everybody it's not
like you're a bad person or you're lost
or you're depressed or you've got some
problem you need to take medication for
everybody everybody regardless their
stature in life where they are
regardless of their money their
relationship
their job they run the joint promise you
no matter how much they present like
they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody everybody
has those days and the Sun is kickin
today has those days where they don't
know what it is
I don't know what to do you know
uncertainty my friend Dale Christiansen
told me when I was 25 years old
experiencing depression everyday is like
no matter what man no matter what no
matter what dude show up even if you as
a bleep show up I've been doing that for
34 years now show up even when I don't
want to okay and then what I try to do
is I try to help one person one person
and what happened over the period of 34
years I did that every day I'm not
depressed anymore at least not for long
periods of time I don't use any kind of
medication don't use any kind of drugs
don't smoke we don't drink over
excessively drink I might have a drink
once in a while and got a beautiful wife
two beautiful kids and for the most part
of my life is freakin wonderful all I
did was this
I don't overanalyze never do i label
myself a loser Twitter I'm hard on
myself I never I never labeled myself
OCD acdad d OCD d whatever a depressant
alcoholic of drug addict no no I don't
this is what I do I do things okay show
up move in the direction I don't
overanalyze move in the direction that
think could be more Pro survival than
staying in one place and number three
help somebody
okay okay I'm gonna go get come on man
who's your poem for that
oh boy I am
[Music]
let me get that for you let me get that
you know my mission I deal with gorillas
curves you can flip around and it's
appreciated salon upstairs door man you
owe me a movie star golfers yeah - if
our muscles man let me get this
the
do you have a beer already fell asleep
I am I know where I live
from here make another copy come on man
1 Canelo do me huh you get back in the
ring let it burn awake over then I gotta
get back in the litter and okay I
thought about this thank you look for
somebody to help man is people all over
this planet man just lost lost look here
my boy right here what's going on man
send up my man's work it you're not
drinking that right
10 bucks dude electrician a Mike Mike
we do this
all we make it 100 a cube and you keep
it Thank You boss yeah Mike I do man huh
what do you do I work at McDonald's uh
awesome man Harry constant man you got a
wife no I don't got kids no you got a
mom yeah man give him some of that I
thank you I hope not you ain't using
drugs oh no no you don't right man thank
you where you from man where you from
what it's all right let's go before that
was your family from China thank you
thank you
I'm somebody man help somebody I know
you want to do that everybody wants to
do that everybody wants to be the guy it
helps somebody out man random dude I
don't even know his name
he's like I'm from it might for
Minnesota a Maine my kamini from
Minnesota come on let's keep everything
you know what today's different today
you should have big smile on his face
right business just like Bob help
somebody hey friends of Evan Carmichael
and Evan my friend but he appreciates
you doing this takeaway on me
I really really appreciate everything
you've done for me and what you've done
for so many entrepreneurs I'm in Malibu
right now Evan I wish you can get away
from New York this weekend come down and
see me we're supposed to be June gloom
brother but instead of June gloom it's
just June beautiful hanging out Malibu
got my staff down here hope you guys
enjoyed these 10 takeaways that Evan
liked I loved what he picked hope you do
too if you have any questions or
comments for me please hit us up Evan
again thanks for what you doing
appreciate you man
god bless it'd be great and believe
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed if you want to get your
pick of who I should profile next in the
top tens check out the link in the
description and go and cast your votes I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Monica test Monica thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word and taking that picture with all
your other books it's an honor to be
with those great books as well so thank
you so much for the support and I'm glad
you enjoyed the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
first thing you got to get right if you
want to be in the sales game today is
you got to get your freaking financial
literacy right you got to get your money
financial mindset right you've got to
start thinking about taking your
finances from the level you are to the
level where you and your family deserve
to be now you know this is true okay
people that are not making enough money
simply make sense of why they're not
making enough money money is not going
to make me happy I'm fine where I am
I'm doing better than people that live
in Afghanistan okay well none of that
makes sense if you have the potential to
make more money if you have a great
product a great company and you know
another call another strategy one more
little maybe angle something that you
could persist with if you know that you
could be making more money and you
aren't
let's get that fixed okay I wrote this
little book called the millionaire
booklet this took me about two hours to
write this took me thirty years to put
together okay this is the playbook to
millions we actually called it playbook
to millions originally and Google and
Facebook wouldn't let me advertise it
because they said you can't promise to
make people millionaires I said no you
can't I can I've made millionaires and
the first thing to becoming a
millionaire a multi-millionaire I hacked
a millionaire or a billionaire and I've
spent time with enough billionaires now
is they have made decisions to get their
money right okay whether they're going
public or selling a product scaling out
they had to make a decision to get the
money the finance model of their
household their business their product
or their IPO right right if they want to
go to the market and become a public
company so number one get your money
right it's not about product knowledge
first it's not about sales knowledge
first it's not about sales process first
it's not about to follow up first off
right in the customer up first it's not
even about attitude first it's about get
your financial mental get your monkey
mental right okay because if you're
satisfied if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it your own
commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
follow up only when it works okay number
one get your money mindset right this is
your target right here you know this is
how big that that's what you should be
going after because this guy this point
over here might actually know you you
know I want people in South Korea and
North Korea to know me I don't care for
communist doesn't matter Kim jung-hwan
Kong whatever dude I don't care I don't
you know I want all I want all these
particles these are particles these are
the people right they're like I want
them all to know money because if they
all know my name dude they send a
vibration to that guy I got it people
don't know you they don't buy from you
okay there's an old saying if people got
to like it about from just not sure if
people have to know you though they
don't know you they won't trust you
the more they hear your name the more
this one point right here here's this
name oh I think I'm truck that name when
I grew up I thought I needed to market
here
this was my market it was a mistake man
mile marker should have been out here
that means you need money though because
a lot of this marketing they're going to
waste it you know
and it takes a lot of energy Mansi you
need your team on the freakin you need
your team for me to market to this one
guys one one one energy level for me to
market to all these people every day you
got to remember these people are in a
different time zone these people so I
get eight hours of sleep out there 16
hours 16 hours a day do with his hammer
down maybe with a 10-minute nap they can
hammer down that means I need my wife
and my kids on with on board all the
time
16 hours I need to hit and early on I
didn't have that because I have two
girlfriends you know he notes coming in
with the camera right those guys over
there not to light up and you got to get
your team right because that's what
you're taking on you're not taking on
his path see this is what everybody goes
into business thing I'm gonna give my
business plan but most the business plan
is this it's a its own is right the
difference what's your business planning
you know you need energy you need energy
to go to these places so I don't need a
girlfriend saying we could complete this
cuddle that I found a couple I'm trying
to do this thing why don't you help me
do this thing and then we got some time
to cuddle you know so really really
important to get everyone in the same
page found and I had an idea took it to
the marketplace learned how to pitch it
change my environment store to hang
around winners where the winners you're
on top of the hill bro stay in the
bottom of the hill and I thought how
they in the Marriott okay they're not
where my mama told me to go my mama told
me save everything save everything save
everything and she told me that for one
reason because she didn't know how to
make money so what I've done but I'm 58
years old just turned 59 actually I'm
gonna spend the rest of my life helping
people figure out what I did
okay everybody should have everybody
sibility this everybody should have the
opportunity to take their families their
kids their wife her husband take them
wherever they want to go okay everybody
because everybody does have Africa most
people just are not willing to read
study learn so now if you are one of
those people here's a little warning
tool but it's got a picture benches
carefully I joke captain Ryan all the
time I like got to run you just can't
you can't listen everybody you can't
study everybody those of you out there
there study and you're like you're
opening up every Facebook feed every
snapchat looking at every YouTube video
you have to pick pick you got a pick
see you good people right you got a pick
who you're gonna launch it okay you got
a pick who you're going to want to come
you have to be selected if I'm if I'm
somebody did you resonate with studying
me okay if I'm not if I'm not forgot
then find somebody that's baited okay
not just money but has time for our
family time for vacation time for
spirituality time take care of their
physical condition time to give back
time for charity time to help the
military out those guys are out there
serving over there look find somebody
that matches your values and study that
person deep